ideally how would you like it done for
this secret hope he lies a great year in
getting one ever sees the feel I mean I
deal
Janet's for them but then is there is
going to be decision whether they'd
contrast away
as that that you really hear you would
not obviously want a little
to the playlist
Nathaniel doesn't play one snap as a
rookie
okay we'll be very happy
John Mary John's Kohner from last week
openly rooting for Eli Manning to be the
wire-to-wire quarterback because that
will mean the team is good and they can
save Daniel Jones for another year but
Daniel Jones continues to prepare to
play Chris Simms after going five for
five with 67 yards in a touchdown in his
preseason debut Jones was 11 for 14 161
yards and a touchdown a throw - TJ Jones
15-yarder late in the half also had two
lost fumbles one was on a bad snap
almost when he got sacked but you know
the bottom line is he continues to check
the boxes right he continues to look the
part and there's going to continue to be
this sense and if this is the Giants
plan it's brilliant that the fans are
gonna be the ones who dictate when the
change happens because they're gonna be
clamoring for Daniel Jones and then when
they get Daniel Jones and if he's just
kind of okay they're gonna be less
likely to be upset because this is what
they wanted
they're gonna find reasons to say it's
good the last half full not half empty
because we want Jones we want Jones and
I think we're getting closer and closer
till we want Jones well yes let's not
say let's say this though Eli Manning
looked good the other night I mean he
really did I can tell he's had some work
done as far as mechanics throwing the
football
it looks like Eli Manning's actually
lifted weights in the offseason for the
first time in a while his body looks
differ in the uniform so the drafting of
Daniel Jones I think put a poker on Eli
Manning's butt a little bit - he's gonna
try to fight this off but til your point
daniel Jones certainly does look the
part I'm not gonna let you know jump on
the bandwagon and yet and go oh my gosh
this is a superstar this is unbelievable
stuff no it's the preseason the Bears
were playing second and third stringers
but either way I think you and I can
both look at it and go ooh there's been
a lot of positives and this kid has a
chance to maybe be something if it
continues to go in the right direction
certainly a great start to this point
they claim that coach Pat Shermer
ultimately will decide when to make the
switch from Eli Manning - Daniel Jones
here's what Shermer had to say about the
starting quarterback situation after the
second preseason game
John owns the team right and we're on
the same page really not much more to
say and I think I've been saying that
all along I just get a sense once in a
while that when I answer those questions
nobody believes me well you heard it
from the owner yeah look I mean the
bottom line is Pat schirmer's not gonna
do anything without making sure that
John Mayer is okay with it yeah Steve
Tisch the other owner he's not involved
John Mayer is to the point where I think
that a lot of the decisions that Dave
gentleman makes or decisions that he was
told to make by John Mayer and and look
Merrill wants to see Eli play well and
so a week one Daniel Jones starting
assignment is highly unlikely they're
gonna ride with Eli until they feel like
they have to make the switch and you
know what Chris that the good news bad
news is if it works and they make it to
the playoffs then what do they do with
Eli Manning next year yeah at some point
you've got to rip the band-aid off at
some point you got to go forward with
the young guy you made him the sixth
overall pick and you got to believe in
him because you already do or you wasn't
it drafted him where you did all right
Jared Stidham 193 passing yards for the
Patriots 14 for 19 he continues to
excite in in a more muted way because
nobody expects him to play this year
barring an injury to Tom Brady but they
think maybe this guy could be the future
beyond Tom Brady's career if and when it
ever ends say the same thing with Daniel
Jones he's got a chance we've seen
enough and two preseason games ago Wow
there's something to this kid he's got
talent he certainly seems to have the
right frame of mind and Moxie about him
as far as calmness poise in the pocket
all those things you want to see from a
franchise quarterback yes again I'm not
gonna jump on the bandwagon yet
because he is playing against a bunch of
second and third string us and things
like that but certainly looks like he
belongs and we've seen enough from his
arm to go hmm the guy can make some
special throws every now and then just
like we saw from Daniel Jones so Pat's
vans giant fans should all feel good
about what they got going on with these
young quarterbacks
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports